[Music]
right welcome to texas now this has been
an incredible trip and i've got to rub
shoulders with some of the best chefs
anywhere in texas and
justin yu has been the focus this week
and my goodness making that guy cook
look at the backdrop you've got the heat
100 degrees you've got the rattlesnakes
you've got the deers you've got the hogs
and an alligator so i'm gonna move my
ass and be quick today so i thought i'd
do something light and simple and show
you the most amazing
beautiful stunning tacker i'm gonna
start off with some of the best
tortillas
founder emmanuel and he makes these
incredible authentic
corn tortilla traditionally they're blue
inside we'll do a little pika to go and
an amazing hang of steak first off
season that steak okay
when i say season it be quite generous
with the salt because i'm gonna lose 30
of it i keep the pepper quite big
okay
and then
tear that off for now
and roll that round there
roll it all in okay
now over to the stove let's get a good
char
on that hang a steak
in she goes
now look at that for a fire
up
and
into the pan
she goes
now i want to sear that okay
i've tilted the pan
so it's rolling down like that and
literally cooking the back of the hanger
steak
manipulate the steak
to the actual shape of the pan because
it's searing all around
now look at these these are abundance
the palace these are the paddles cactus
to the naked eye lightly season
okay
gently rub
the most amazing
olive oil on there now these are quite
robust
but
once you start cooking them
they taste delicious it's almost like a
really nice tough
sort of salty
leathery piece of asparagus straight on
to the open grill okay
on there
and grill that now look at the steak
look at that roll that round about two
minutes each side and literally the same
for the cactus
two minutes i want the char on there
okay charlie's gonna give a really nice
flavor
i'm gonna start
with the pico de gallo okay let's give a
sort of a nice spicy flavored salsa
really important for taco it's the base
red onion
less harsh
than the white onion okay
down one side
and
again
don't get too precious when you think of
the taco it's not about the finesse or
the cuts it's all about the flavor so
build this thing but don't get too fancy
with it i'm going to hit that now
with some
lime
straight away straight off the bat
because that's going to make it so
fragrant
lime zest in okay
lime juice in half for now
squeeze that in there okay let's get
some heat in there
beautiful little chili peppers hold that
up i want the seeds in there and all you
do is put the tip of the knife in
and pull it back twist it round
pull it back and then literally look
go through you've got this beautiful
nice dice
that goes in
onion
now we start with that olive oil just a
touch to bring it together
okay
look at those colors
that lime is gonna really start kicking
in for now let's turn
the pales
that's what i want a beautiful texture
on there
now look at my hanger steak
roll that round
come back to the scallions go quite
big
we need that beautiful sweet onion
flavor cooling down there pico de gallo
okay
use the greens as well all the tips in
there really important
now
that needs
the heat of the cilantro
just take the cilantro roll the top
around and just chop it once don't go
any more than that don't over chop it
otherwise you'll lose out on that flavor
really important now hit that with a
touch more
olive oil beautiful and then finally
the tomatoes look at that
slice them
into three
seeds again
the secret behind any great taco is not
getting precious it's the build-up of
the flavor the tomatoes gonna give it
the sweetness but more importantly
it's gonna give that really nice soft
cooling
effect to the taco
down seeds in
okay i get so frustrated when you miss
out
on those seeds now take a spoon
and start rolling it around
a touch of salt
a touch of pepper in there
and keep it quite chunky
okay i don't want it too wet if it's too
wet
and as you know
it becomes sloppy spoils the tortilla
and then finally just take a little
blade of garlic
okay
and just do the same to the garlic as we
did
with the pepper come down
down down down
down down come along just like you do
with a onion
look
and we chop the garlic nice and fine
that goes in
beautiful look at that steak
that's nice and rare now i'm gonna take
that off
okay
and then let that sit on there
and rest
does that rest i want the cooking juices
on there
look at that beautiful
now
take my paddle
beautiful
so lovely
let that cool down a touch
now the secret now is not to slice the
hanger steak immediately
okay really important
all the way down
got a beautiful crunch on there
so tasty
and then look
slice that through
that goes in now that peak of the guy
is going to go crazy now finish that
with a touch of olive oil
it's seasoned beautifully it's ready to
go we slice that now come down
down
and down
just lightly fan that
and then very beautiful corn tortilla
now these are traditional beyond belief
toast them very very quickly
onto the grill
here we go on she goes toast them
now i say traditionally having the
chance to make them
this week here and really understand
seek of a great masa
and the importance
of the authenticity and the taste is
incredible and the nice thing about this
particular tortilla is it absorbs all
that juice
so
think of it as a cushioning
but a cushioning with flavor
a light toast on there
super light
beautiful once they've gone slightly
curly the side
lift them up
and place them in
to your mould
that way as it sets
it literally
starts to
shape a beautiful
tortilla shape get them in there and
literally in 30 seconds they will set
beautifully everything's big in texas
everything's bold in texas
and everything's in hot in texas
honestly
i'm sweating like a rabbit stuck down a
hole with a rattlesnake
the most exciting part
first off i'm going to load that up
with my peek of the guy
okay
in
that's the base see the importance of
keeping that nice and dry look at this
beautiful hanger steak see the grains
we're slicing on the grain
not too thin
slice down
down
down
we load that up
in
in
in
in
a light seasoning
from there just a touch
of that peak of the guy oh
and boy
for the final
garnish
take three slices of your creamy avocado
each one
and then finally
run that
left to right
i'm going to hit that
with a touch
of lime
beautiful
and then take my fresh
cilantro
twist it from the top
slice it
once through it don't go back through it
just once i want the flavor in the
cilantro and then hit it
and there you have
a proper
delicious
stunning texas
taco
with a proper pico de gallo
aron sanchez
eat your heart out my son
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch on catch up
on disney plus
[Music]